[Music]
just moments ago a procession began
that will bring the queen to st george's
chapel that's in windsor castle for a
final public service of remembrance
charlie douglas along that route in
windsor which is known as a long walk
i've been there charlie when we were
there for megan and harry's wedding i
know what a wonderful place it is good
morning to you
[Music]
good morning to you gail and yes the
atmosphere is incredible here at the
long walk throughout the morning they've
been watching the service on these
screens it's gone black because there's
a warning that the presence of horses
might spook the horses here
as we push up it gives you an idea of
how many people are here it's hard to
estimate
a couple hundred thousand is what
authorities have said they've been
gathering here awaiting the arrival of
the queen and the procession that will
walk past here along the long walk up to
windsor castle now there is where you'll
see the rest of the royal family joining
you can hear the cannons going off
behind me
joining that procession which will be
the last public event that we'll see
that will be the last televised event
where they have the committal service a
much smaller service than you saw at
westminster abbey and that will take
place here at st george's chapel after
that there will be a private service
around 7 30
this evening and that will see
the queen laid to rest finally beside
prince philip her husband uh her father
king george vi her mother the queen
mother all inside windsor castle itself
and that will wrap up the day's events
but people have been coming here because
they wanted to share in this moment a
lot of people here are from from windsor
a lot of people from all over the
country just to be here for this final
moment this final farewell for the queen
i know charlie they were telling us in
the paper this morning they expect two
million people to come to this area for
this day thank you charlie